welcome everyone to the data science
hangout
i'm your host rachel dempsey um but for
anyone who's just joining for the first
time this is an open space for current
and aspiring data science leaders to
connect and chat about some of the more
human-centric questions around data
science leadership
but really it's just an opportunity to
focus on questions that are most
important to you all as well
so you can jump in live or put questions
in the chat
and we also have a slido link so you can
ask questions anonymously too
and robert i'm sure we'll share that in
the chat window in just a second here
but just a quick note this will be a
recorded session so we will share it up
to youtube
for anyone that missed it
but i'm so excited to be joined today by
my co-host jacqueline nolis head of data
science at saturn cloud
and jacqueline's led data science
machine learning and ai projects also at
microsoft adobe airbnb and t-mobile
and she's also co-wrote the book on
building a career in data science
so happy to have you here today would
love to have you introduce yourself and
maybe just share a little bit about some
of the work that you're doing today
sure um so hi everyone i'm jacqueline
nolas uh yes i
um
a little bit about me i got an undergrad
in masters in mathematics then i went i
want to go get a job using data to help
businesses this is before data science
was a term so i did that for a while
then went and got i said nah i want to
go to academia i got a phd i said no i
want to go back in industry so then i
consulted for many years um including at
a bunch of the companies rachel
mentioned um
and then i um
recently uh started um maybe not that
recently anymore i'm now the head of
data science at saturn cloud and saturn
cloud is a um
a cloud platform for data scientists to
um run jupyter notebooks and things like
that and use das clusters for
distributed computing um
and i will say i've used r for about 10
years now and it's been a really fun
journey and r is my favorite language to
use these days even uh even if the
company i currently am employed by is
more of a python place
and jaclyn i think
it's also helpful for people maybe to
understand some of the projects that you
work on at saturn cloud as well and like
what your team looks like too
sure well okay so throughout my career i
have started to lead data science teams
like when i was a consultant i created a
data science department on my company
that had like eight data scientists nine
managers managing that got really big
then like when i went to t-mobile and
helped consult there i like helped them
start their ai teams i've done a lot of
helping teams start and then growing up
teams um at saturn cloud i'm actually
because we are a product for data
scientists i'm less of a like do
analytics and build models and more of
like product development of like what do
data scientists like want and you know
how can we build documentation and
examples and like help our customers
solve their problems that kind of work
and so that's what the team i lead does
now but it's actually the thinking of it
is fairly similar it's not as different
as you'd expect from purely i'm going to
a rhema a neural network kind of data
science
awesome so i get to ask the questions in
the beginning when people are thinking
about what they want so
i'm curious what's something that you're
really excited about in data science
right now
um
that is a great question i think that
i have found it really fun
to watch in like the last three years i
would say maybe a little more than but
it's gotten really easy to use the most
cutting-edge models i would think like
it used to be that like well like you
know way back when like well you could
use a linear aggression or or a logistic
regression or maybe if you really put
some work into it a random forest but if
you wanna do something advanced you need
a blah blah and now it's like man with
pie torch tensorflow uh xgboost like gbl
like they're really the difference
between the most powerful models and the
powerful models that are powerful enough
that you can use them on a day-to-day
basis gotten really small i think that's
really cool because we have to
there's less like oh you only use a blah
blah blah you have even tried to use a
blah blah there's less of that because
we can all just kind of use everything
now so it's just not as big of a deal um
so i appreciate that that is kind of not
as much of the conversation as i feel
like it used to be
um so maybe the thing
of data science is it feels like there's
less gatekeeping than there used to be
and i think that's great
that's awesome
and i know i got to talk to you a little
or i feel like i got to talk to you at
our studio webinar where we had the
building effective data science teams
um even though that was julia
interviewing you
but i something that i thought was
really interesting that from that
conversation
was this whole idea of like distributed
versus centralized data science teams
and i know you had a kind of set idea on
on that and i think it'd be interesting
for everyone to hear a bit more about
that too
yeah so i will actually tell a story
around this so this is back when i was
the head of a data science team at a
consulting firm and
some like were like some like one of
these gartner reports like forrester
kind of a company was asking us like
what is your stance on distributed
versus centralized data science meaning
do you think at a company the data
scientist should all live on
individual teams like you should have
the data science marketing and the data
science blah blah blah or do you should
you have one central data science team
that all the data science reports you
and there's more like a consulting firm
that kind of goes out and helps and um
at the time when i was working on this
and we're a consulting company we didn't
want to harm and offend anyone we did a
very consulting company thing we just
said uh you know we think there's
there's reasons why you'd want to use
all of them you know and we just kind of
like absolutely punted on like who's to
say what is the right thing and i
actually held that belief for like in my
heart for a fair amount of time i'm like
different models for different companies
there's always a good place for some you
know and now in 2021 i feel actually
pretty definitively like in most
situations the
decentralized method is better which is
to say have your data science teams
really close to the people who are there
helping is better than having data
scientists close to each other because
the data scientists get close to each
other what do they do they really like
talking each other about really complex
models and building really complex
things when you have the data scientists
close to the teams they're working on
then you actually can like solve the
more practical problems like i think
there are uses for companies having
consultancy style data scientists going
in and helping with like the tricky
stuff but i do think it's better to have
data scientists scattered throughout
and how like have you ever had to go
from one way to the other or
to
distribute everyone
i
think i have almost well like i've
either been at like a small company
where like we just have one data science
team because there's only 50 people um
or
usually
well actually i've kind of been on both
i've been at companies where there's
just one central data science team and
i've been on companies where
um
each team has its own data science team
i do think there are times where all of
them backfired like i've seen teams um i
worked at a i consulted for a certain
large um tech company and they had
within one product they had like 10 data
science teams all basically doing the
same thing all fighting with each other
and like that's not a good use of
decentralizing so i've kind of been on
all of it but yeah i think having your
data scientists close to the people
they're trying to help is still like the
generally right call also i don't know
if you guys can hear my cat is super
loud and annoying so i'm gonna go kick
him out of the room and i'll be right
back one second
or just bring bring the cat to the
hangout
bruno says show us the cat
that's next week's speaker yes
[Laughter]
i follow up on that and yeah sure
how um
so specialization right to an extent is
a positive thing
how do you
[Music]
feel about having the person that is
awesome at forecasting sitting in just
one of those business unit teams
versus the person that right has spent a
lot of time doing cluster analysis and
then and then figuring that out
um
do you see
not that i disagree with you or
wholeheartedly i'm just looking at the
other side of it when you have these
these individuals who are really really
good at things and then they get stuck
kind of in a corner which is great for
that team that has them but not so great
for everybody else in the company
how do you see that that balance playing
out or or have you seen it play out well
anywhere i think that that what you just
said is the justification for having
some sort of internal consultancy like
if you really have a rockstar forecaster
put them on the team of people that goes
around and just talks to the other
people to like get their forecasting up
um like i think if you have a hundred
data scientists at a company you could
have 10 or something who are that style
of like i'm just going to go around and
make all of our forecasting better and
then the other 90 are actually like more
in the field doing it
i'd said i think there's actually a lot
of risk too in having people specialize
i've been in a lot of situations where
like
and maybe it's just because i tend to
work at smaller companies but like
people think have a desire to specialize
too quickly and like oh we're gonna have
this person like there's so much risk
and having this one person be the
forecast person and they're gonna do
forecasts and no one else knows how to
do forecast but that one person like
then you that person gets bored of
forecasting if they quit your company's
really bad position you're much better
off i feel like avoiding those sorts of
scenarios i'm making so everyone knows a
little forecasting or at least like
like 10 percent of the people know
forecasts and they can swap around
rather than having everyone um only have
one specialty like
i think
i i think i've seen occasionally
problems where people don't specialize
enough but much more often problems
where people specialize too much
and again i think it really depends on
company size so
how do you also have
the team like i i'm imagining when it's
decentralized and you said it's not as
many data scientists just all talking
together how do they also help
train each other on different topics or
like keep up to date on certain things
if you're working on a separate
department
i don't know like i think you can get
clever with like slack channels and like
monthly meetings where we all get
together and just socialize right like
that's more about like creating human
connections than it is about like having
an internalized process but like if
everyone's friends then it doesn't super
matter because like until it goes wrong
you just go ask your friend um so that's
more about like creating human
connections than like formal processes i
would say
um
but i don't know i think that like also
like at some level
like
i don't know i usually learn more about
data science from blog posts than i do
from coworkers so like it's less about
having all your co-workers talk
necessarily some internal information
maybe but like a lot of it's also just
like making sure your data science teams
have the time to go out and learn new
things and stay informed
thank you i see there's an anonymous
question that came in
um
that is anaconda enterprise in our
studio community at first glance they
look feature equal if you had to choose
one
i mean i'm here i'm not on it
um i mean i really like i'm really happy
with what sort of things we're doing at
saturn class like i'm i'm pretty happy
with the kind of tooling we're building
there but i do think from what i have
seen on the python community it is just
it is a lot of work to try and create it
get it to be as um
get it to be as um
i don't know nice and social as the r1
for whatever reason i think our
communities are just more like fun-chill
places to bake but again i don't know
that's where i came from so maybe i'm
biased
i think that leads to like another
question that i would have as we wait
for a few others to come in but
um
are you pretty open across your team too
like whatever tools
people want to use or how do you
standardize on
certain tools okay so
i will say i
i have watched a lot of teens crash into
the ground because there's one person
who likes spss and so they you know spss
so they're going to write an sdsm rather
than them learning the language everyone
else uses
i have been that person not with spss
but with like f sharp like i have i have
committed that sin and i have i have
personally crashed projects to the
ground because of this i think there is
a very real risk of letting people go in
and do whatever they want and then
having chaos
i also think concurrently that if you
never let people use the tools they like
your product your employees are sad and
also your product is less good because
people like particular things for a
reason so i think any time you put in a
new technology it is a group decision it
has to be some level of group like
thinking like like um
at the last company i was with like we
were primarily using python and we're
like going to use r and like do we have
enough people to support r blah blah
blah like like that is a conversation
and not just like well i like r so i'm
gonna use it um
and i think this is especially hard if
you're one of the very early people on
the team because every time you make if
you're the only data scientist and
things start every decision you make
about well i like this best is also a
decision for all the future people so it
really uh matters that you think about
this stuff so i i tend to lean on this i
guess i lean more on the authoritarian
no don't let people use whatever they
want because i watch it so much crashes
in the round and then i'd like try and
fight that back a little because i'm
like i gotta let people be happy i guess
so
um i think oh sorry oh no problem do you
mind if i ask a question yeah though
okay
um jacqueline with the idea of the
decentralized i'm a big proponent of
that one thing that i wish i could get
to be more successful is
letting people move around a company
so i've i've been successful over my
career actually getting decentralized
but then often the groups
the managers over the groups that have
the data scientists don't want them to
ever move anywhere
and i'm not sure how to get
more buy-in from
the higher executives to help push that
along so i think that really helps build
that community and the friendships where
you start getting the good collaboration
without the overlap have you jo any tips
there i would love to hear your
no but i will i will i will not do i not
have tips but i'll answer a different
question that's related to your question
so it still sounds like i'm insightful
well i will first say i've never
actually done what you've described i've
been working at one department of the
company and then switched to a different
i've always stayed in a cup in a
particular team until i've been like
left basically um for whatever reason
it's just not a thing that i really
pursued
um
that said i think what you're describing
is something i have dealt with a lot
which is when i think there's a culture
change that needs to happen at an
organization and i don't know how to get
people to notice that um in your case
the culture changes people lock in too
much on hey
i like this employee so they're gonna
stay with me forever and not hey it's
better to let people move and grow that
helps everyone like the tragedy of
common style like that is a culture
change i have a lot of times been at
companies where i'm like we are doing
something that is disadvantageous to our
whole company but the people at the top
don't understand it um
and i need to help them do that
here's the bad news which is i've been
in lots of those situations i don't know
how many of them i've actually succeeded
in getting anyone higher up than me to
really change a culture you know i'm
just a i don't know maybe you can notice
this about me i'm a very outgoing and
loud person and so i will really bring
up these sorts of issues of like hey we
need to let people go around more things
like that and occasionally i can get
people above me to make changes but like
more often than not they're like well i
don't know and it's just like there's a
certain like power imbalance where like
i can never make people with more power
do things and
i've had to learn how to be very
strategic about deciding when to really
push on stuff when to just let stuff go
and not care about it or when to say
this is so catastrophically bad it is no
longer worth it for me to be here um
so i don't know if i have necessarily
tips on how you can make those get those
sorts of changes to happen but what i
would say is maybe the better question
isn't how can you make them happen it's
when you're in an environment where you
can't make the things you want to happen
how do you react to that
yeah actually sorry i've been in a lot
of these situations where i've had
people above me really making bad calls
including some like diversity stuff
where like it's like i just yeah it's
very frustrating like i put a lot of
heart and soul into it and then just
have the people that may be like yeah no
and it's just like yeah it's very
demoralizing so i'm getting a little
worked up thinking about it wow that's
terrible leadership
that's why i don't worry about companies
anymore
i feel good like this is an important
topic to stay on for a little bit and
i'm curious if other people have
other tips or advice as well
i will say the last five years of my
career have in large part been a form of
me learning how to navigate these
situations because i think that really
as you get to like principal levels and
up it's just more and more hey the
people at the top have some ideas that
maybe you don't agree with and what are
you going to do with that
so oh not only they have agrees they
don't do this you don't agree with they
hire you to fix those problems and
they're like we want you to fix these
problems also we won't let you fix these
problems what are you gonna do let's
just like that's just a very
how to handle that has been a thing i've
really been focusing
on and is that something that you also
are training people that work for you to
do or like how to have those
conversations
um a bit
a bit i'm also trying to not be those
people right like i think there's just a
certain amount of like how can i be a
good leader and make sure that the
people under me are given both clear
direction of what they want them to do
and a clear understanding of what they
can and what i as their leader can and
cannot do and why
um and make sure those are in sync and i
really have been trying more on that but
i do think training people to be good uh
navigating and that's important as well
eric i see you have a question you put
into the chat um which i'm not gonna
just read so i'm gonna ask if it's okay
if i uh turn the mic over to you for a
second absolutely um first jacqueline
huge fan of yours and i'm just gonna say
gg irl is just straight up amazing i
will keep saying that forever um
as a shiny enthusiast i'm still i even
watched a recording of your new york
presentation just recently amazing stuff
anyway it kind of leads to what i'm
about to talk about here is that
um i work with a lot of people that ask
for my strategic input on maybe
scoping out a data science tool whether
it's a package or a shiny app or things
like that and i give them some high
level recommendations and they start
prototyping it
and this prototype can go
quite quickly from
some of those just meant to show how
something worked
so then they just
build and build and build on top of it
until
you get to a situation where the
leadership wants to use this in
production but it is most definitely not
ready for production because of some
shortcuts they took and things like that
so i guess from your experience what
have you
done to still encourage innovation in
your teams or with your colleagues but
yet when you sense that maybe
something's about to get really popular
really quickly
how to empower those you know developers
to think about
well it's probably going to be used in
production so i might want to shore up
this area or things like that i don't
know if you have thoughts about that
so i will say that in a sense this is
actually very related to the last
question because
i think maybe every question anyone
asking on this chat i'll be like these
are all the same questions right which
is in your case it's like at some level
people at your company have an incentive
to put stuff out the door because it
makes them look good and like you are
helping customers presumably like
presumably isn't that benefit um you
also have an incentive not to have this
blow up on its face or not to be checked
at you know in the next year where
suddenly you're like oh this is a huge
hurdle and if we just put five you know
extra minutes of effort in so you have
these different incentives and it's kind
of your job to be the person to like
even if you don't have the most power
you kind of have to do this thing of
like well how can i as a person who
isn't have the most power try and guide
the team to doing the right um
the right thing and i think
because you can't just tell people no
you can't rule this out yet the best
thing you can do is really it's like
this is like a like a soft power like
discussion sort of a thing of like well
let's talk about what the risks are of
rolling it out here and like why we care
about unit testing and like these sorts
of things and as much as possible a lot
let's say it's a unit test let's say
let's say you make a cool api and you
haven't put a unit test in it they're
like cool let's just put in a pod
something like unit test you could go to
a person be like you really need to put
unit tests in it and they'll be like
whatever teach like i don't know what
that means that sounds like a lot of
work and the more you can both tell like
explain to them why hey you're united
testing upside these things blah blah
but then also if you can actually like
write some unit tests set up the
scaffolding like a lot of times the
reasons why people don't do things isn't
because they don't want to make stuff
good it's because they don't necessarily
know how and sometimes even just setting
up a little bit of the scaffolding can
really go a long way and i think that's
kind of what i think about like a
principal data scientist job it is like
entirely to do that it's to help like
get people started in the right
direction so like write the first unit
test think through what is the micro
service architecture going to look like
so we don't build a giant monolith like
just trying to do that kind of stuff in
a in advance in a way that's like a soft
power look let's just i showed you let's
just see if we can do it i think that's
kind of like
um
that kind of uh stuff really helps
yeah one follow-up on that is uh i'm in
an industry
that historically has been kind of
lagging behind and thinking about these
newer ways of thinking of how data
science is a very
intricate field that we have lots of
touches on just the statistics side but
also the
software development side the
architecture design and sometimes it's
hard to get some leaders to recognize
that the skills that you literally just
mentioned of
scoping things out correctly getting
them set up correctly instilling these
principles early on
is not something that's in people's
typical job descriptions for the role
i'm in
so sometimes it's for me it's sometimes
been a challenge to get these kind of
skills recognized and valued accordingly
so i don't know if you've experienced
yeah let me give a very concrete example
of this so as i imagine most people on
this call know it is generally best if
you
have code in a shared repository that
people commit and push and pull it is
generally worse if you have a data
science team where everyone has
everything on their own laptop with no
structure and different formats like
maybe they run this report once a week
but if they threw away the laptop you
have to rebuild the whole report um
so i had one at one of my consulting
things i've gone just from just from
being a team where everyone uses git and
we all have a clear system with folders
and blah blah blah to uh like a team of
like 30 data scientists 90 of them
didn't use get some of them like i said
use spss blah blah and like
that is bad that is bad for a lot of
reasons um if someone were to leave that
company be really bad like we can't even
keep track of like what code actually is
running in prod because everyone has
their own stuff now when i come in to be
like
i objectively know that the team i've
just been working on before with git and
folders and whatever ci cd that is
objectively better but to try and do the
work of
getting everyone to switch to using git
and a shared language that is a massive
amount of work i could not do that i
don't even think and i've thought about
this a lot i don't even think the person
running that team of 20 could have
gotten everyone to do that because the
problem was just so big at that point
had they started three years earlier
would have been fine but at that point
20 people all these different systems it
just would be very very difficult so i i
do think there's a certain point of like
point of no return of like we just have
to accept that this is not gonna be a
system that runs well and hope that as
they build future systems it will and as
much as possible trying to catch it up
early so you don't get there too
absolutely thank you
you're welcome man think about the stuff
it's like it's bringing back man imagine
being on a team with no get and some
people use spss like
i don't know
so there's actually there's an anonymous
question that just came in on how do you
structure internal documentation or
communication channels so people can be
empowered by the internal data science
team
so i have maybe two hot takes that i
think are maybe not generally like
standard what people believe
one is i
think that a lot of times data science
teams write too much documentation and
two i don't think they put it in the
right place i think they don't think
enough about what the right place for it
is which is to say um let's say i am a
data science team and we have some
stakeholders work with us
um one thing you might say is like well
the stakeholder is asking us questions
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
write like a doc on our wiki page and
it's going to be a huge stock with every
question answered in it and a data
science team will spend weeks building
this giant repository of all this
information and then what do you know
the first thing is no one looks at it
because it has too much information even
if they did look at it everyone has new
weird questions that show up so they
that those docs wouldn't really answer
the docs are written to avoid having to
take meetings and stuff with these
people but in fact
you still have to take just as much
meetings now you've just spent weeks of
times building something that you then
also have to maintain so i think there's
this natural data science feeling of
like well if i just write everything
down people will stop talking to me
anymore i don't think that is generally
true
um i think the best kind of
documentation data scientists can do is
one
for themselves i think within your code
having readmes having your functions
documented having good testing good
variable names like that stuff i do
really think helps quite immensely and
making sure all this code lives in a
shared place where it's not like we have
a github repo for one thing and a git
lab report for another envelope about
like just having things organized is
just as valuable as documented
and then the other thing i think is that
yeah you really can't document your way
out of talking to stakeholders and the
best thing you can do is just getting it
so stakeholders know that what is the
most effective way to communicate with
you is that if they have a request you
drop it in the jira board is it hey
there's this the per this is the project
manager they always take the meetings
like just having that clear system so
you can't minimize the work but by
having it in a flow you can at least
like manage it as opposed to fire drills
requests coming everywhere i think that
stuff is far more valuable than like
yeah that's right lots of docks
what kind of system do you use for
requests
so
i do think that you have a person on
your team who's the project manager
person and maybe that's actually a
project manager maybe that's the
principal data scientist whatever but
someone whose job it is to triage
requests
you then have when anyone has a request
they want to make of you um they either
talk to that person or drop it in the
jira board or whatever board and then
that person looks at it tries to
understand it goes back to them has a
meeting about it to really clean it up
and then from there the data science
team tackles it i think some sort of
intake method like that works best i
think creating a standard form that they
fill out that kind of stuff doesn't
really work because every question will
never fit into a form because i always
have this weird edge cases and i also
think um
yeah i think just having a person who
everyone knows the point of contact on
this just makes it a lot easier and like
i don't know i find that job really fun
i love talking to people about what
their problems are like so it's not
necessarily like a bad job but it is
something where you should you should
have one person who's really the point
of contact on it so it's not like well
some requests go to me and some requests
go to blah blah blah and some oh they
they have to have a lunch with this
person back when people have lunch
together now they have an extra request
like having one clear point of contact
really helps
thank you
ian i i see you asked the question in
the chat around building a team up from
scratch do you want to jump in and add
any more context to that one
sure i hi jaclyn i just wanted to know
um
you mentioned going in starting all of
these teams from scratch
was there a common denominator
uh this common um thing that you would
experience um in companies where
there's maybe not a data centric culture
or
there's not um a big understanding of
what data science is
um was there a common thing that you
know hurdle or something you had to
overcome to kind of get buy-in or you
know just to even start the team off
yeah so a couple of things i mean
usually if they are hiring you
there's got to be like some vague buy-in
at the company in the sense that like
you wouldn't have been hired if at least
someone somewhere didn't think data
science would be useful so
i have because i guess i would which is
to say i used to worry that like am i
gonna get buy-in for this that's kind of
gone away usually it's like there is
buy-in but there's a total lack of idea
of how to actually make it work which is
to say and i've had this happen a few
times where you come to a company you
start a team but the question's like is
there actually data we can use is this
data actually useful right like so if
they hire you with the expectation of
like you're going to build machine
learning models on the revenue data to
blah blah blah and then it turns out
like two months in that like there's not
enough data here that you'd ever be able
to build models on it or stuff like that
that stuff keeps me up at night but i
don't think there's any real
way to solve it besides before getting
hired really try and like probe on if
this seems like a good chance for data
science and really just being flexible
with once you do start like it may turn
out that the actual data science work
you're doing isn't what you originally
expected and it's just like that's kind
of the learning experience of being the
first one
um
i will also say
to the previous or earlier point when
you are the first data scientist you do
you are
the first data scientist everything you
do sets a precedent if you pick r or you
pick python now everyone's going to use
r python if you use the kit repo
like so it really more than any other
time
you being careful about what you're
doing
is
going to pay off in the future
and also
you have to at the same time and here's
the twist you can't just be like i'm
going to build a beautiful cathedral of
get repose the ci cd blah blah blah
because you'll spend the six months of
your time setting up all this tooling no
one else to use it yet and after six
months of not actually doing work and
just building tooling you will be let go
and so it was all for naught so it's
like it is like a strategic game of like
where do you actually invest given you
can only do so much investing while
concurrently trying to produce revenue
um i think being the first data
scientist is extremely fun but that is
quite a stressful thing and like i don't
know that's maybe not for everyone
awesome thanks
it sounds like maybe that has happened
before where you get there and you don't
have the data that you actually need to
do what
they want you to do like how how did you
actually handle that
well um
[Music]
you have to have some real frank
conversations with your leadership about
hey you hired me to do thing x y z but
think x y and z is impossible let's talk
about what is possible and how i can do
it and if you have a strong set of
leaders they'll be like you are a data
science expert i trust you on that let's
have that conversation and pivot and if
they are weak leaders they will say well
you just don't know enough about data
science we're going to keep doing the
same thing because we know more than you
and then that is like a not great
situation those are the sorts of
situations where like ah me being here
isn't really right for me or you so
yeah definitely
um julie i see you just put a question
into the chat as well on uh tips for
denying requests would you want to jump
in and provide any other context for
that one
sure absolutely so i work at a
hospital where we have a fairly new data
science team and the problem with
hospitals is that they tend to be very
hierarchical
in that everybody's first idea is always
would go as high up in the hierarchy as
possible to ask what we should solve
whereas
i maybe have
the understanding that the good ideas
actually come from the people who work
with the patients and do all of the
stuff where whose work we're supposed to
be helping
um and i haven't figured out a good way
to triage um where
um people i work with are not
necessarily comfortable saying to the
high ups that this is this might not be
the best use of our resources
and i
also
am not senior enough to maybe be able to
do that myself so if you have any ideas
on how to
as you say like try to bring the reality
into the conversation that would be
really cool
so i will first say you said well i'm
not necessarily senior enough i think
that is a student observation which is i
think a lot of times people get on these
calls the way like you could be the
lowest person at a company and if you
pitch your idea just right people are
going to love it and like that's not
really true like they're like positions
are real and sometimes being more senior
gets stuff so like i think it is
good that you are aware that that stuff
exists and you're navigating around that
um that said the most luck i have had in
these things in these sorts of
situations is just trying to like pivot
the pitch from not like hey more senior
person you're wrong and here's why
although that's maybe how i feel but
much more like hey how can i show you
senior person the things i am seeing
that are making me think that the the
more junior way of doing things are
right so if like the senior person like
we need to build a whole new data
platform or whatever and you're like no
we really just need to like
go survey some hospital beds right like
the more you can be like well let me
explain why let me show you some data
like the more you can kind of it's not
like hey i need to change your mind it's
like i'm gonna bring you into this new
even better idea like that kind of
thinking helps which is to say most of
what you're kind of asking about and i
think has repeatedly come up on this
call is like
organizational dynamics and like the
things that have helped me the most in
my career get good at these are books on
like negotiation and like getting to yes
and difficult conversations just like
thinking answering the question of how
do i convince another person to do the
thing that i think we should do um like
that's that is totally unrelated to data
science and very much a like business
philosophy like argument
meta conversation you know like and i
think just really thinking about it that
way and trying to look at those
resources help but like it's very tricky
and it's um i i would love i would love
more than anything i have an answer view
of like oh well if you just said these
three words then they they have to do
here's the code words but uh at least
i've not yet found anything of the sort
and that was uh that was a really good
tip on the looking into the negotiation
literature and stuff like that thank you
so much bye you're welcome
yeah thank you i was just saying in our
little side note clip that that portion
that was really helpful too
um trevor i see you just asked a
question to around um
when you're the first data scientist do
you want to jump in and ask that one
hi hello everyone
um very interesting conversation with
jacqueline right um so you spoke about
i've been the first data scientist in a
company or a big
startup it's
and the point that you made about also
do you have the data that you need to do
data science
so i'm asking when you typically enter a
company do they have the data already
and do they have it in a way that it is
useful
or do you also have to think about the
structures that you need to put in place
to get this data to a stage where you
can use it to build models i don't know
your what your experience has been like
throwing that
yeah
so i think not i think you're correct
and i think um
yeah with you're the first person that
the data might not be in the right
format for you and you need to figure
out how to make it the right format you
might have to build your own sql
database you might have to
set up a cloud thing like you have to do
a lot more of that work than if you're
an established company um sometimes
companies do have data engineering teams
before they have data scientists you
know if they have been collecting data i
know it's valuable so like
the like
it doesn't always end up being the case
but it is quite common and i think
that's part of the tricky part of being
a first data scientist i will also say
that not only do you have to be a data
engineer but i think you also have to be
a data analyst which is a lot of your
job as a first date scientist might just
be taking data from a csv summarizing it
making it into one chart in a pdf file
and then emailing it to an executive
which i would argue is it's not like
data science work it's more like
analytics
um but like that's part of your job too
and you're not gonna get to always just
build super cool models when you're the
first person um and i think
that comes with like the struggle of
being the first just like you never know
exactly what your job's going to be like
and you just have to be ready to roll
with whatever punch that will help grow
your team and your company um also you i
don't know if you guys have seen this
when i'm a very fidgety person so i'm
picking up like the thermos and my
speaker and everything yeah so yeah so
products are follow-up question there
because
first data scientist right so the
assumption there is that the company
that you're being hired in that they
know what they want right so when they
ask for a data scientist i mean
do you see them asking for
someone with a background in data
engineering or
they don't know what they're asking for
i think i've seen almost every time i've
started been on a start of a data
science team i think i would say 75 of
the time they did not actually know what
they wanted they knew they had data and
they knew that if you take data it
somehow turns you into money it turns
into money like you know they understood
that from like they read the harvard
business review articles but they don't
really know much more about that and
they know a data science person is the
kind of person who does that and so you
as the first hire may have to come in
and be like actually you don't even need
me yet you need a data engineer or
actually what you really need is not
data science but analytics right like
there's so many angles that could go and
like that's just how it is and like even
companies that really seem like they
should know what they want from data
scientists sometimes they just unless
you already have data science
established you just you don't really
know what it's going to be like
thank you
and uh shifting gears a little bit to
hiring conversation i see jeff you just
asked a question about hiring new talent
would you want to ask that live
and i can read it as well it says as a
data science leader what are the pros
and cons of hiring new talent or trying
to upskill existing talent
um
so i will say i don't
i don't super
i don't super feel like it's um
it's like a um
binary i guess i always feel like i as a
leader i always want to be upskilling my
employees which is to say at every turn
i should be trying every day regardless
of hiring other people or anything like
that i should always be trying to make
sure my employees are working on things
that are challenging them and helping
them grow and they learn new skills both
because that gets me
more things that they can work on at the
company and it's good for them because i
get new skills and have presumably more
fun doing it so like i just i think that
um the upskilling is just like a
perpetual push forward of people and
like that's
like never changes
uh when it comes to like the pros and
cons of hiring new talent of like when
is it valuable to for your team i really
struggle with this because i do think
that um
when you hire more people then that that
actually is a really big burden on your
team both like you have to give them
work to do and make sure they are
content and communicate with them and
have them kids like that's a big draw so
i
i think i tend to be a little bit more
conservative in my hiring just because i
find that terrifying i'm more terrified
that and than i am of terrified of not
having enough people um
which is i think just my personal like
personality showing up um but like
there's just it's a very real
calculation of like how much do you want
to take on the risk of like have not
having enough work and your team getting
too big and blah blah blah versus the
risk of missing opportunities because
they didn't have people around so that's
kind of the challenge i'm always
balancing i also have a blog if you want
to like literally how do i like
interview people and stuff i do have a
blog post series which is on my personal
website if you scroll back on the blog
enough that goes into all of that um
it's a little old but like that thinking
there so like i've have that system
pretty well figured out of like if i'm
looking for a data scientist how do i
get them in the real risk is just am i
getting them in at the right time
thank you and we can add that blog post
to the chat as well or if we can
find it robert maybe
it's pretty crazy.com
and going back to the question right
before this someone just asked if we
could clarify maybe what is the
difference between a data scientist and
a data analyst
oh okay great question i would say a
data analyst job is to take raw data and
get it into a consumable format for an
executive right so if you have a sql
table it's an analyst job to turn it
into an excel file that has just the
summary monthly numbers and put that in
a dashboard and these sorts of things
this is a challenging job because like
what are you you know if you're dealing
with like sales data what about returned
objects and what about this and like
well if we do that then that rather
actually changes last month's numbers
and that would be weird can we do that
like there's like a lot of work and
thought that has to be into getting
executives that data
a data scientist in my opinion is a
person who's more focused on they get
a data set and an abstract question of
like why are my customers churning how
what is the best offer to give my
customers things like that and a data
science job is to like build models do
regressions forecast whatever to try and
answer those things so a data scientist
is more about using models to answer
questions and like do inference whereas
a data analyst doesn't really build
models they just take data and group
aggregates summarize and visualize and
thoughtful ways that people within the
company can use it um and i think
companies have like a thousand times
more data analyst work than data
scientists work and i think there are a
lot of data scientists there who like i
would never do data analysts work and i
know because i used to be one and i was
very snobby about this early in my
career and now i do a lot of it and it's
fine but like there's like a mental
hurdle you have to get over of like
things aren't less interesting or
numerically challenging just because
they don't have a regression in them
so
on the topic of roles i see will you
just ask the question a few seconds ago
would you want to ask that one now yeah
sure so as far as data science roles i
guess teams you mentioned kind of a
project manager earlier data engineer
data scientist what do you recommend as
far as the types of roles in a data
science team
it super depends on what your team is
right if your team is like primarily
like making reports doing analysis like
like you know doing an analytical like
trying to answer these questions with
data
that is different than you're building
actual models that are going into
production that sort of thing i think i
mean obviously you need data scientists
i think after you have like two or three
data scientists you probably want to
have like a principal person or like
this a person who is like job it is to
like coach and help out on the other
data scientists so i think you need a
lot of that
i also do think having someone whose job
it is to do project management which is
could very well be that principle um
that's valuable too i think having a
manager is good if you get big enough
again a principal style person can also
be a manager and be a and a manager
could be a project manager so there's
all kind of overlap but like okay so let
me i'm gonna start over here's what you
need
you need data scientists to do the work
you need someone whose job it is to help
those people technically when they're
not sure about stuff which could be
convincing them to do unit tests or
whatever and checking for that you need
someone who's a manager whose job it is
to figure out that the work coming in
makes sense right like a manager's job
is to like hey are we asking are we
working on the right stuff are we asking
our tests are our employees growing and
are they getting the right comp or
whatever like that kind of stuff and you
need someone who's a project manager
which is like literally like hey person
x from this department asks us to do
this does that request make sense do we
need to flush it out how does that fit
into our like list of work that's like
five roles on that team a lot of those
can be bunched into the same person but
depending on what your company is like
it may make sense to do that bunching
differently um in like the most abstract
case you have three data scientists and
manager principal project manager person
does all the other stuff um but i think
it really depends
thank you
so follow-up questions from the analysts
and data science topic as well if you're
a data analyst today what tips do you
have on making that transition over to
data science
so
um
i think it's a lot about learning
learning the regressions learning the
models getting more comfortable because
analysts are more likely to use sql and
excel and those sorts of tools and are
in python and the more you can get
comfortable with arm python the better
like there are boot camps right like a
data science bootcamp is a thing
designed to get you those skills you
need real quickly it's
it's also at some level so it's at some
level getting those skills you are
missing but a lot of times when people
ask this question it's because they are
an analyst and they are interested in
this stuff and they learn some r in
their free time and now they're trying
to figure out but okay but how do i
actually get the better job and then at
that point it's a lot of like crafting
your resume and stuff to like
actually um
like highlight that hey analytics work
is very similar to data science work so
look it's not really much of a stretch
at all for you to switch positions so at
some level it's about like marketing
yourself as it is as much about getting
the right skills and things like that or
using internal opportunities if you can
switch teams and that sort of thing to
see if someone could switch you within
your org to um
get more work i will say i have a
co-wrote a whole book that has
discussions about these sorts of things
and you can get it at bestbook.cool with
the offer code buildbook 40
for 40 percent off
love it
um on on that topic as well i just
remembered there was a question from
earlier that i hadn't asked yet and this
might be in your book too but
when you do determine that it's time to
leave a company
how do you explain that departure when
looking for the next job okay so we do
have a whole chapter on leaving your
company
what i do is i mean i guess it like
super depends if it like like i think
it's very
one
oftentimes people don't even ask because
they don't see it like it's often not
too real but if they do ask you can be
like hey you know i've been at the
company for a few years and i was
looking for a new opportunity and that's
fine and feel good cool got it you got
bored no problem
i've been in situations where like i
actually left because of the stuff we
talked about earlier like i have
incredibly toxic boss or whatever and
like what i do there is when i go to um
my interviews i say they're like well
why'd you leave i'm like well you know
what after being there for six months
they're just very clear that there
wasn't necessarily a fit in terms of
what they wanted data scientists to do
and what what i thought was the right
stuff to do it just like wasn't a quite
right fit and that's like a wink-wink
nudge nudge for like it was a bad talks
environment but like no one questions it
so like there's a lot of
there's a lot of ways you can say i
don't like working there anymore that's
still like middle class sound like look
we're being professional and fun aren't
we um and i think that you just kind of
have to like practice saying the words a
few times then go into the meeting and
it's fine
i like that like actually practicing
saying that out loud first
yeah
yeah i gotta break it in a little
there's a few other anonymous questions
that just came in so i'll read them um
one is if you're talking to an executive
leader how would you explain the core
value that a data science team brings to
the organization
so
how would i person if if like i get
asked into the office by the ceo of big
name company
like forward to 40 company whatever
and um
they're like jacqueline what is data
science why should companies use data
sets i would say
look
i'm going to use my executive voice
whenever you're asking that question
let's uh let me grab my martini no um
so
i would say look companies you generally
collect lots of data what products
people are buying how are they are using
them blah blah blah you also have to
make a ton of decisions both like in the
abstract sense should we
use that data to do stuff like or sorry
in the abstract sense of like should we
launch a new product or not like or like
that's just a decision we have to make
and then like a very like concrete
day-to-day question of like
hey should we send this customer this
offer blah blah blah
you could totally make that decision in
a vacuum and that's fine companies have
done that for a long time but like
wouldn't it be a little bit better if
you use all that data to try and do
things like hey let's not send the
customers who
um will who will purchase from us
regardless of if we give them a coupon
let's not just hand them a coupon and
lose money right so like like or you
know what comes that product we can
clearly tell from data that like that
product probably won't be helpful for
people let's let's know that and so i
don't think data science ever gets you
like a your company went from a failing
company to a huge success of data
science but i do think like you can like
on the margin improve your product a
reasonable amount and like make things a
bit better by um having data science so
i don't think like data science is the
right thing for every company to
suddenly grow huge but i really do think
especially for bigger companies with
lots of data and lots of opportunities
to improve stuff that data can be just a
very nice way to kind of flush things
out
that
is why thank you cause that's why i'm
running for president
um
so another question for you as president
of data science do you have any tips for
pitching machine learning projects to
non-technical leadership specifically a
mid-sized company that has not had a
formal machine learning project in the
past
i think what i honestly think there is
that's less about really like machine
learning projects can be huge to
implement but they can be pretty fast to
show that they would be valuable right
so if you have a if your ideas we're
going to try and find customers and use
a machine learning model for which um
which coupon they're going to get it may
be a huge effort to get the data sets
all connected and blah blah blah and
actually have this run every day but
it's pretty quick to
take a one-time abstract of the data run
a model on it and show look we think
that these customers would behave
differently right like so like
with machine learning i feel like since
so much of the work is actually the
productionizing you can sometimes like
under the radar do the work of proving
it's valuable then go stop that to
everyone be like hey isn't this cool
wouldn't it be cool if it happened every
day automatically for our customers and
that at that point i find it very easy
to get executives who see a poc of
machine learning to like buy in it's the
hard part is like just making sure you
can actually craft the psc in the first
place
plc being proven concept
thank you i am i'm scrolling through to
see if there are other questions that
i've missed so so far so feel free to
jump in live too
well if you're not going to talk okay i
have another question
about um engineering so
i'm curious how
for your engineering needs like putting
things into production or creating
servers specifically for your work
are you
do you have your data scientists or a
part of your team that can overlap
between those two worlds
yes both the data scientists have to
become they have to be like they don't
like write like the best code in the
world in like c plus plus but they have
to like
you know be comfortable with the idea of
like a docker container of a unit test
and that stuff i found it's not very
hard to teach a data scientist i was a
data scientist you do not know that
stuff at one point and now i do i don't
think it's that hard i think data
scientists are sometimes intimidated by
that and they need good mentorship but i
don't think the actual knowledge is hard
to learn what is critically important is
that your team is partnered with an
engineering team right so whether you
actually have engineers within your
group who will do this or the engineers
who are going to be rolling this out sit
right next to you or you have everyday
stand-ups things like that because if
you don't have that super good
communication it's just not going to
work both because your video scientists
aren't going to build something that the
engineers use but also the engineers
will not be able to provide some of that
mentorship in like hey what do we look
for in unit tests or what do our docker
files how do our docker files you know
our docker containers roll out so
for machine learning stuff it's just
essential that you have engineers and
data scientists very close together and
collaborating
how have you how have you gotten that to
happen
it seems hit and miss with with me i can
get certain people who seem to speak
like a very more traditional i.t and it
works well there
so how do you hire data scientists to do
that and how do you get the engineering
how do you get to the like that
communication going better like i've
i've not been totally successful unless
the data scientist is more intrinsically
interested in like the
more i.t
portions i do think there is an
intrinsic interest part like i do think
that stuff matters but i also think what
matters is is the engineering team like
doing this for your team as a favor in
their time if they have it or is like
part of their core charter to help the
data science team roll out data science
um because i've been in both those
situations and unless they're unless
they are not like the thing they are
hired as engineers to do is support the
data science team it's very hard to get
them to care because like i don't know
people like talk like working with
people who know their stuff so it's a
lot easier for engineers to just keep
you know not communicating similarly
data scientists are much happier to
communicate with other data scientists
than data engineers so it's really like
levels above this making sure that the
two teams are like the leaders are
talking and then i'm like it's like and
it's not like just that engineering team
does eight things of which one eighth of
that is uh support the data sciences
i think that's what i need
it's charter on my engineering team okay
i see mike you just asked the question
that came in do you want to jump in live
sure i can jump in live jacqueline i'm
also a big fan as well and i know that i
think you've talked about data science
consulting on your becoming a data
scientist podcast at one point but it's
been a little while since i listened to
it so i figured i might ask this
question again and you mentioned that
you worked in data science consulting
you know at one point in your career i
was wondering if you have any sort of
tips tricks best practices that are
unique uh to finding success as a data
science consultant and in the consulting
world uh you know dealing with a lot of
non-technical stakeholders as well the
sales process of selling your value
that's unique to being consultant as
opposed to an employee yeah so i will
say i do talk about the book i have like
loosely toyed with the idea of like
writing like a like a five chapter ebook
just on consulting data science because
so many people have your question of
like i find this stuff interesting how
would i a data scientist get into
consulting
um
so consulting has a pattern like okay so
super high level how do companies hire
people they have
employees full-time employees
they have it's generally called like
contractors or vendors who are like hey
we just need you for a certain number of
months to just work as like our team and
then they also have like consultants
like more consulting consultants like
we're bringing you in for a very
specific task so
it is possible to as a individual be in
that last group of like people know you
as like you're a good person for this
kind of stuff so they're just gonna
bring you one
by far by far the hardest part of all
this is finding getting companies to
know and trust you and like like finding
the work is a thousand times harder than
doing the work um for me i had worked at
consulting companies for many years so
like i had built connections with like
companies i had consulted for as part of
one point and then i was able to talk to
them as an individual so like a lot of
it is just how that is how i built the
network there's multiple ways to build
the network or like of people you work
with and more than anything what i
recommend if you're interested in this
kind of stuff is like try and find
someone who would hire you and then do
it in your free time like do it in your
evenings and weekends and that sort of
stuff um because if you do it that way
it's like a nice you're testing it out
you're um
and if it works that's some nice side
income which can be really valuable and
i recommend charging like real they
charge more than just whatever your
hourly salary is like double or triple
that
and then um
if you do that and do that enough times
and you like it and stuff then you can
start thinking about making it your
full-time life but that's a hard thing i
also think working at a consulting firm
is a very valuable way to learn these
sorts of things in terms of like well
how do you make that first contract and
what is the sales cycle like there's
just a lot to that that is unrelated to
data science and just a standard
consulting thing but like it just takes
time to like figure out the beats of it
um and it's something that it's helpful
to like
try and experience or like get an
insight into how that works before you
go out on your own and um
sell that kind of stuff so which is so
which is to say that being a data
science consultant is very little about
being a good data scientist and
extremely much about being a good sales
person thinking through contracts
thinking about like what's gonna happen
if this company won't pay you for four
months like it's like that kind of
management and all that kind of stuff um
which can be fun and eventually a very
financially lucrative if you can pull it
off but it is also tricky and i no
longer do it so
did that answer your question i don't
know
like i would write an e-book about this
so
that's super helpful thank you
jacqueline
and as we get to the top of the hour or
two i just want to make sure to ask
what's the best way for people to get in
touch with you if they have follow-up
questions is it twitter or linkedin a
great question i don't really check
linkedin please twitter dm me um at sky
touch s-k-y-e-t-e-t-r-a
um that is the best way to get it um and
like a lot of my talks and blog posts
and stuff i have all my personal
websites if you just go to janelles.com
you can see a lot of my past material
so awesome
thank you so much jacqueline
are there any other questions from
anyone
that i don't think i miss any from the
chat but if so please jump in
just seeing a lot of thank you so much
jacqueline that was awesome and it was
really fun chatting with you i really
appreciate your time and
looking forward to hopefully having you
on here at a future session too
perfect that yes this is a lot of fun so
thank you for inviting me especially
you're just getting a rant about stuff i
like ranting about so that's great
awesome
thank you jacqueline have a great rest
of the day everyone
you